[Music]
I'm Connor from Fishtown analytics I'm
here to talk to you about your favorite
like sexy New Wave Data technologies
sequel so I live in Philadelphia I'm the
co-founder of a analytics consultancy
called Fishtown the analytics so we help
like venture funded and growth stage
companies they let their analytics
discipline in addition to that we build
an open-source data modeling tool called
DBT which we're going to touch up in
this talk and I come to data engineering
through the same route because I think a
lot of us has formerly like a senior
application developer dev obviously
engineering manager those sorts of
things at data companies and then one
day somebody decided that I was an
engineer so okay so why talk about
sequel I think like Siebel is very old
and it's everywhere and so a lot of
people know a lot about sequel but I
think one sort of novel thing about
sequel right now is that with the advent
of technologies like a query and
snowflake and redshift we've really like
democratize cloud data warehouses to the
point where a lot of small companies are
able to use these tools that formerly
were only available to very large
companies so we can give serious compute
power to people that like all we know
sequel or maybe sort of less technical
than a lot of data engine and I think
the other thing that we found that's
that may seem irrelevant is sequels just
like the lingua franca of data there's a
lot of people that know enough sequel
looks dangerous or can pick enough that
they can do some damage with it without
necessarily needing to have an end
background so it's a good tool to use
this are like common language with the
less technical folks business users and
so on that are companies but sequel has
some limitations it static is
declarative there's not like so much
that we can do with it so this song is
about how we can extend that make it
more powerful and get a little bit into
DBT so I think the obvious sort of
example or parallel that we can draw
here is to something called HTML for
those of you that have an application
development background have been have
been doing this for awhile you've seen
things like this so let's say we wanted
to create a user's page where we had a
list of links and each link linked to
the profile page of that user there was
a time where there were two ways to do
that one was like if you wanted to add
another user you would type some HTML
code and like FTP that up to a server
and check then take it and deploy it and
you'd end up with page with another link
on it or you can print this like
horrible like PHP stuff were you kind of
like print out HTML and generated as you
work your way through code but after a
little while people figured out that
this wasn't a great way to do this
number one like there's a whole group of
people who know HTML who can't
understand and like probably don't want
to understand the stuff on the bottom
there and we really like want that group
of people to be able to like it
contribute to this as part of our stack
so people came up with this idea of HTML
templates so the idea is you have mostly
HTML of an inside the HTML you have some
other stuff that adds some dynamism to
the code that you're writing so this way
we can instead of either typing more or
running a for loop we can sort of
smoothly generate the pace that we were
trying to generate so the parallel is
sequel is easier a sequel like HTML is
text based its declarative so we have a
similar idea here like you can just
write a query that works well in a lot
of cases or you can write this like
messy stuff in the bottom that like
spits out some sequel as you accept
flags and those sorts of things I hope
that no one is doing this and that
you're using like our to generate this
when you're using some library to
generate this type of code but this is
sort of how this stuff works under the
hood and so the basic idea of this talk
is like why are we doing this thing
let's use templates with our sequel so
this is an example of a change of
template that can conditionally add
we're close to a single statement and
can kind of like modular we filled up a
sequel statement using these things
called CDs so for those of you who
aren't familiar with TTP's this like
with this as select start from orders
table that's called a common table
expression and that's a way that we've
defined if you'd like a name at this
query has basis
okay
so why is this a good idea I think like
with HTML we can just write better and
nicer sequel by doing this we can do a
lot of things like we hit the open
source code we can you know like share
this code as if it was sequel with other
people in organizations and outside of
organisations but I think really like
the power here is that we can do some
things to make sequel more capable so we
can develop actually like the advanced
functionality that NRC will reach beyond
just and with that comes this idea that
like we can actually check this code in
to a git repository and make our
analysts who are bringing sequel code
work like software developers so we'll
talk a little bit about that but really
this helps this type of like
transformation code or its analytics
code fit into the way that the rest of
your data engineering team is working at
your organization so the rest of this
talk is really just like fast and
furious rundown of some use cases that
we developed here a lot of these all the
code that I'm going to show is like
valid DVT code good news if you use Det
and we'll talk a little bit more about
what that means as we go but the idea
here is that you shouldn't have needs to
be to use some of these ideas so you
could if you were so inclined you can
install Jinja and start writing your own
oh boy this stuff to read okay so one of
the basic things that you often want to
do in sequel but it's really hard to do
is a pivot so if you look on the right
here at the top we have an input table
that has a size and a color what you
often want to do is just get like a
count across those two dimensions
so we want to say like how many items
are there in this database that are red
and small how many are there that are
blue and medium and you want to build a
table of all those values so it turns
out that like Siebel is infected doing
this kind of thing but it's a use case
that analysts want to achieve like
pretty often so the way that you would
normally write this is you would write
like case when color equals blue then 1
l0 end case when color equals red then 1
l0 end and like our HTML example you
would sort of write these statements one
by one so what we've done here is to
bring a macro in Jinja that just does
that so you give it the column that you
want to tip it over you give it the
values that you want to use but with it
and it will just generate all those case
statements for you it sort of
dynamically inspects the database to get
the values out so one problem with
writing it yourself is when we add a
color green to this table then we don't
have a green comment somebody else does
so we now have this ability when we run
this code again full automatic inspect
that Basin include 3 has a new column
so in other kind of use cases
materialized views are materializations
as we call them so there's this idea
that like you might want to take a
select statement that you run frequently
and then just run like create view as
and then pass that selecting them so
anything you might want to create a view
you might want to create a table you
might want to create an external table
you might want to create some different
constructs and your sequel database
depending what you're doing
but all of them sort of take a select
statement as the input and then spit out
some kind of constructs in the database
so this is sort of an example of how you
might do that so given this like with
input as selecting which is just
defining the Select statement we can
then pass that select statement into all
these different materializations
buildings in different ways by passing a
configuration parameter into this code
so if we wanted to do is write a bunch
of statements to say so any TVT we have
like a bunch of materializations that
leverage those concepts we have using
tables which I just showed external
tables but we can also do things like
build tables incremental e so when you
have a source table that gets new rows
we can figure out what the new rows are
in that table versus the table that
we've already built and just bring in
the dip and we can do things like a
British tables a big query and add sort
and distribution
so there's really a lot of power you can
dynamically adjust the sequel that
you're writing based on the tactics
so another use case here is tags and so
this is sort of a secret sauce of duty I
guess so this is a pretty typical like
analytical query you know I can read
that that we see so the idea here this
is snowplow data which is an event
tracking system and we have this no
class sessions table its Rosco class
sessions table that is all the sessions
as given to us by the snowplow system
and also this is no public view map
thing which is like ID user I mean that
bit so this is just a query that takes
those two tables and joins them together
it's like for any two sessions has given
to us by snowplow have different user
IDs but we know that they're actually
the same user we can combine those two
session we can do those sessions the
right things are I think quite a
transformation and this is like the
simplest sequel but it's sort of simple
to understand like there are two inputs
to this and then there's one output that
just has a different user ID and it has
a new session index field that tells you
what number of sessions but it kind of
gets complicated when you start to think
about like the number of transformations
you might have your company so if you
have 30 things single scripts that look
just like this it's pretty hard to track
how those pieces fit together it's hard
to say like they just run all 30 of
these in order and make sure that
everything's gonna be built in great
order without manually managing you need
to tell your system that this table
depends on Rostow plus sessions so in
DBT we built this concept of RF
essaouira is a function that you call in
this template library it does two things
so first it prevents out to like scheme
on table so it's just going to reference
that table and in the background it
basically that's some metadata that
represents an edge in the graph here so
when you go to actually run this no
class sessions its strengths and its
predecessors like its dependencies DVD
can work this out and run both of them
in the correct order so like as you
start to build these up what you end up
with is that where each node in this tag
is table or a view or something that's
built in your warehouse that is like an
artifact that's actually there and you
can sort of pick and choose different
sections like so grass within the static
that you want to run right so if you
want to rebuild just this very you know
top right node here we can sort of
easily traverse the bus back and figure
out like okay
doulton puts our visa bill we changed
this notes we need to go a lot of
chocolates so I think the thing that
really falls out of this is like this
ability to go curated data sets and
think this is something that has been
talked about a little bit so we can
break these things down by like into
groups of raw data these intermediate
transforms which look like that so class
session we just looked at but maybe
that's not something you actually want
your end-users to very directly but you
have this ability to create maybe in a
difference a set of production
transforms that these people can look at
directly I so it really gives you a lot
of power to control like what what
things when I give to users what things
you don't what things are wrong
so this is one example of a dag that we
have built this are the actual tag for
the snow plow example that I gave the
students be dead so you can see we start
from this like snow plow base offense
thing we have a snow plow base web age
context which provides more context for
those events and then we sort of go
through all these elements of the deck
and end up with the three things that
your that data page reduce obsessions
and users and then all of our analytics
are powered by those three things so if
you get this live back to the talk I
have a link here to the code for this
yes just to give an example of the
curated data set version of this this is
a dag created by our sleep so their
company that's using PBT the way that
they use it is they give their users are
their customers our raw event deep so
it's very difficult to read with this
leftmost thing here this is called
parsley raw data and that's just the
table look like all of the raw events
they're going through our system so they
should those two like their customers
red ship cluster and then all of these
transforms down here are defined by
their community project they'll ship
into an EBT project that you can run and
generate all these that use case
specific tables downstream so again it's
very difficult to read but a lot of
these happen to play abuse on video
content he was on most content page
views all these sorts of things that you
would want to analyze from your users in
specific rather than just getting this
okay so in short you sequel it's great
these templates they're awesome if you
have any questions questions okay come
to questions and you mentioned
application development yeah part of
your earlier career yeah how do you see
this in relation to things like
lrms and maybe more generally just using
a full programming languages alongside
this to do more advanced transformations
they're like full-on software developers
yeah so like one of the things that we
didn't really get into of this is
outside transformations part was
definitely very important so in relation
to no RM I think with an ORM you're sort
of defining this language over single
you're basically saying like I don't
really want to write sequel I want to do
something else and the idea here is very
much like sequels the tool so let's use
that as much as we can and try to
that yeah on the outside transformations
piece I think one of the ways that we
are seeing people use their warehouse is
most effectively is to run these types
of single transformations and then run
other transformation pipeline to relay
data out of the warehouse from
transformation pipelines on it and
upload it back in and this software
practices right now but I think that
that again like getting everything into
the warehouse is a really important step
typically democratize all this data and
give your analyst access
elaborate on the you're talking about
barbecue kind of break out of teammates
here to do that yeah I guess you know
our people typically these using
workflow engine like airflow or
something to orchestrate this and then
but at that point the I guess if they do
that then from air flows perspective DBT
is like one huge black box with loses
all the tags right
and so hopefully how do you deal with
that yeah that's a technocratic so DBT
is a command line tool so when
somebody's using DBT with airflow
they're using like a patch operator and
they invoke DVT and other models and
then they put that in so that might be
one Operator and all the operators that
depend on this data are separate
operators inside so we've seen a couple
different ways that people use this one
is that there's some people that like
break out their DBT tag into air flow
tag I think that one of the things that
weren't working really hard on it's like
how do we get this better than
extraction so yeah as today that's as
follows
we're not you know I mean you can see
what looked a bit and one thing that I
guess also question it seems like given
that it's kind of come almost like a
macro compiler for sequel the UK
yourself this spa where he's like
incredibly ornate or large single
statements you don't know what's
happening and I like I started having
like PTSD when I was using C++ templates
and they really have thousands like if
this thing insane error messages and
stuff house one if you run into that
etc yeah it's definitely consideration
one thing that we make sure to do in DBT
is like every that we compile the
grinders down to a single script that
you can then go back and you know again
because some of these database
technologies are so mature it will tell
you like a you have an error like
monthly to of your crazy single scripts
and then you can just go back in so
that's helpful but yeah I agree that as
these tools get more complex that
you